[Musique]
au sud de la bretagne entre terre et
océan il existe une petite mer
intérieure parsemée d'une myriade de
petites villes
pour découvrir ce lieu trois femmes
trois habitantes du golfe nous ont
ouvert leurs portes
marie-gabrielle s'est lancé dans la
production de spiruline à base d'eau de
mer avec son invention révolutionnaire
elle veut conquérir le monde mais
concilier vie de famille et succès
professionnel n'est pas simple
tu devenue insupportable
grâce à sa
forme
marie-gabrielle va faire une rencontre
qui pourrait changer sa vie
edit et l'infirmière de l'île d'ars ici
pas de médecin ni de gendarmes et dit à
la charge de tous les habitants de son
île
et elle ne changerait de métier pour
rien au monde
carmen elle est une jeune retraitée qui
a choisi de s'installer ici après une
séparation
elle reconstruit sa vie grâce à ses amis
sur les bateaux traditionnels du golfe
du morbihan elle va devoir faire ses
preuves pour devenir première équipe
hier et barré c'est charmant petit
navire
marie-gabrielle n'est pas une bretonne
comme les autres
clés d'ailleurs elle n'est pas bretonne
du tout
mettez vos chaussures
cette mère célibataire de quatre enfants
est originaire des antilles
elle a choisi de vivre au sud du golfe
il y a dix ans pour y devenir
ostréicultrice mais il y a trois ans
marie-gabrielle s'est lancé dans une
toute autre culture que celle des
huîtres et c'est un pari audacieux
[Musique]
comme tous les matins
elle dépose son dernier fils à l'école
puis elle longe la côte de la presqu'île
de rhuys pendant deux kilomètres
c'est là dans cette ancienne ferme
ostréicole
qu'elle a installé son laboratoire
le matin je regarde tous j'observe tous
mes bagages
de boer à nettoyer celui là est bien
concentré va pouvoir servir de
récolte
marie-gabrielle cultive de la spiruline
une sorte d'algues qui se trouvent dans
des lacs des régions chaudes et qui
auraient des vertus exceptionnelles pour
la santé humaine
wickens place est superbe
et ce qui est unique au monde sait
qu'elle a réussi à la cultiver dans
l'eau de mer
la spiruline marine mais trois mois à
arriver à maturité
dans quelques heures je prends tu m'as
dit
mais les plus anciennes alors j'ai
fait un pataquès
tu as besoin d'imprimer bas quand tu dis
pas non je te laisse lancé
super
[Musique]
et donc pas la spirale et marine ça
c'est un produit précieux répression de
fraîcheur la bataille du moment les
seulement des onglets faire oui parce
que je sens qu'un euro kg
ce lieu on était très diminué
grâce à son invention sa petite
entreprise pourrait connaître un immense
succès
mais le problème c'est qu'elle n'a les
moyens d'embaucher qu'une seule personne
une seule journée par semaine
le reste du temps
elle est seule
au cou mamie m ah oui un petit creux
j'ai même très sain lavez le bassin ça
donne faim
[Musique]
elle travaille beaucoup oui
et aimerait la voir plus souvent
on est très fiers de voir tout ce
qu'elle est capable est prête à mener
mais on ait envie de garder aussi pour
notre
lobera voyage dans l'open
marie-gabrielle ne s'accordent qu'une
demi heure pour déjeuner avec sa famille
[Musique]
donc il ya une activité toi bientôt pour
faire si ça c'est ça dont un quart
d'heure
sur lequel se sont épuisés dans la
proximité avec votre grande famille les
pauvres leur énergie puisque chez
devenue insupportable
donc je leur pisse leur énergie grâce à
eux ils sont à plat puis moi je suis
repart plus en forme
ces bassins en tout cas c'est ce que me
disent mes deux grands disent qu'est ce
qui t'arrive mon garçon l'amour je puise
l'amour dans la vie de famille et la
raison
marie-gabrielle n'a pas pris de vacances
depuis quatre ans le dévouement que vous
pouvez craquer ça m'arrive
qui se passe pas
en général tout seul dans une voiture
je laisse déborder l'émotion
et je vais voir la mer et je me
ressource
dans quelques jours marie-gabrielle aura
un rendez vous décisif pour l'avenir de
sa petite entreprise
un chef étoilé l'a contacté il veut
tester sa spiruline dans un plat
gastronomique
[Musique]
dans le golfe du morbihan au détour
d'une île on peut croiser de drôles de
petits bateaux à la coque noire et bleue
ce sont les ferries de la compagnie le
passeur des îles
depuis quelques années ces bateaux
anciens en bois sont devenues l'un des
symboles de la région
marée montante ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on a le courage
parfois leurs vieux moteur est tout
juste suffisant pour affronter les
célèbres courant du golfe un des
endroits les plus périlleux de bretagne
subit des coûts
entre les deux îles en forme de sabre de
courant ça nous donne le deuxième corps
en plus fort d'europe
ça veut dire
non
malgré les risques les passagers sont en
confiance et ce bateau en a vu d'autres
ça fait presque 50 ans qu'ils naviguent
dans la région et françois le capitaine
koné le golf sur le bout des doigts
regardons va arriver dans la veine d'un
bientôt à peu prendre d'autres lots
tempête c'est flagrant là si on regarde
la flotte ici il ya un espèce de clapot
abominable
qui est générée par le courant est si tu
fais 30 mètres devant ou là si tu vas là
la mer est plate et là ya pas de courant
[Musique]
toi tu es obligé d'aller choper
contraire à la côte
[Musique]
voilà la taxe haïr accroche le bateau là
on avance un nouveau revêtu voyage pour
aller chercher la côte
et c'est gagné
les passagers pour pouvoir débarquer sur
l'île de gavrinis au sud du golfe
ces bateaux carmen les connaît bien mais
sa passion à elle c'est la voile et son
territoire ses ports anna plus au nord
ce matin elle a rendez vous avec son
capitaine il s'appelle jacky et il
n'aime pas les retards
carmen s'est séparée de son mari il y à
peu à 64 ans une nouvelle vie commence
pour elle
elle a décidé de devenir équipières dans
l'association les amis du sinagot où
elle doit faire ses preuves et sinagot
ce sont ces trois vieux bateaux typiques
du golfe le mahb air grippe le joli vent
et le trois frères
emmenez le trois frères à vannes pour
lui refaire une belle toilette avant
placer son poids
ma mort
à bâbord
a dit non mais
revenge ap
à bord carmen ne ménage pas ses efforts
photo l'équipe hier à moi
surtout devant jacky un ancien officier
de la marine nationale
[Musique]
c'est la première fois je te vois
travailler
tu vois comment tu me donnes
jeu la mare au deuxième là
le bateau à 74 ans il doit être démâté
et déposé à terre
voilà belle manoeuvre
la pluie a fait gonfler légales y en a
du mal à les enlever mais on va y
arriver
pour les sept pièces pour pouvoir
enlever
c'est un vieux bateau c'est un peu
complexe des points
ça y est déconseillé mais ça va ou non à
terre à terre le trail du sud
oui bien
si délicat quand même enfin c'est un
grand professionnel charles mais quand
même il ya toujours
ya toujours un risque
que ça lâche quelque part
[Musique]
mais assez marrant non
cette voiture manquait
frédéric tu me passes tu le revends
[Musique]
les sept tonnes du trois frères sont à
quai
le bateau va être bichonné
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est suffisant
comme j'ai fait l'un
des plus d'algues ses propres après tout
si
le sinagot sera remis à neuf dans
quelques jours
et pour le voyage retour
carmen aura peut-être la chance de tenir
la barre
[Musique]
au milieu de la baie
l'île d'ars et la deuxième plus grande
île du golfe du morbihan
découvrir cette île n'est pas facile car
ces 160 habitants n'ouvrent pas leurs
portes à tout le monde
sauf peut-être à edith l'infirmière de
lille
les journées de cette femme sont très
différentes de celle d'une infirmière du
continent
je suis un peu en retard et après j'ai
mes prises de sang
sur l'île d'ars et dit l'infirmière
commence toujours séjourné en ouvrant
les portes de l'église
voilà et tous les matins c'est un rituel
j'allume des cierges bien sûr je met
l'argent correspondant quand même et en
pensant à tous les gens que je vais
rencontrer dans la journée maintenant il
faut vraiment que je vais faire mes
prises de sang
voyez là on entend les oiseaux
c'est tout
bonjour blue bonjour à 17 ça va
c'est l'école
allez bonne journée
cette partie
c'est bon tu poseras le point sa parole
en ça va
oui mais comme d'habitude fait d'ouvrir
l'église d'abord tu me la fonction multi
fonctions polyvalent exactement
bon allez voilà pour un
bon allez au revoir
ici tout est toujours plus compliqué
les échantillons doivent être transférés
un laboratoire sur le continent
voyez c'est ce sac là qu'il prend le
bateau tous les matins avec le sang
précieux des îles d'arrêt
il ya un petit peu plus de 23 ans
j'ai débarqué ici
après une vie plutôt mouvementée enfin
en ayant bourlingué pas mal
de par le monde
edit a commencé sa carrière à médecins
sans frontières
venet a priori que pour un an puisque
linda recherchait désespérément une
infirmière
et dès que j'ai mis les pieds sur l'île
j'ai été quasiment envoûté et un ans et
s'est transformé en 29 ans et demi
et aujourd'hui elle connaît chacun des
habitants par son prénom
bonjour maryvonne bonjour c'est un jour
spécial oui bon anniversaire
merci
ans 23 années edit à partager les
moments les plus intimes des habitants
de l'île ça je m'en souviendrai toujours
des moments où lugo a fermé les yeux on
était toutes les deux ont traduit vous
souvenez on a même prié ensemble juste
avant qu'il me ferme les yeux et c'est
vrai que ça c'est des situations qu'on
ne trouve pas en ville avec l'infirmière
qui
présentait qui s'occupe de tout c'est
presque pour moi c'est vous êtes de la
famille et de la famille
attention les affaires reprennent
allo
edit l'infirmière de l'île d'ars peut
voir jusqu'à trente patients par jour
mais il ya un rituel qu'elle ne manquer
sous aucun prétexte
tous les matins je vais à la supérette
acheter un chausson aux pommes pour ma
chère belle-mère
et je vais prendre un café avec elle
aussitôt après
c'est immuable
et la boulangère de l'ilmc hui
d'ailleurs qu'un seul chausson aux
pommes par jour spécialement pour elle
bonjour
alors je viens chercher le chausson aux
pommes damian s'il te plaît
[Musique]
voilà
comme d'habitude je sors sans payer
exactement voilà
exactement oui
[Musique]
tiens un petit passager clandestin
te voilà ma jing
hop
on est là
leur fameuse chanson
agnès la belle-mère d'élite à 88 ans
chez ma belle fille idéale oui mais
c'est peut-être parce qu'elle en avait
mais là aussi
il apparemment
et bientôt dans le chausson aux pommes
c'est surtout les pommes qu'agnès
apprécié
quand est ce que tu vas l'apache aux
palourdes parce qu'il faut regarder le
du rda riche du collège paul griffiths
hier j'ai pas regardé là parce que moi
j'aurais bien aimé faire des aveux
forcés
bon allez agnès à tout à l'heure
voilà
miss golden à sa fenêtre ah
bon donc donc je commande la pharmacie
jaurès a probablement au dernier bateau
sociaux tu te dis à demain dominique
bon courage
linder fait globalement 3 km sur 3
il ya beaucoup de petits détours donc si
bien que le plus que j'ai fait sur les
dards depuis bientôt 24 ans en une
journée je me souviens j'avais fait 99
qui leur est rappelé
pour les 160 habitants de l'île est dit
est une sorte d'ange gardien louis l'eau
bonjour
sur l'île d'ars il n'y a pas de médecin
il n'ya pas non plus de gendarmes
parfois c'est l'ange gardien qui se
charge de l'ordre public
oui qu'est-ce que vous avez lors pas vos
pieds ah oui des objets un peu
compromettants voilà allez
qui on appelle alors bizarrement je ne
sais pas pourquoi alors à défaut du
maire dans le maire n'est pas là c'est
l'infirmière je ne fais pas de karaté
non judo non plus lente avec windows
même pas même pas maintenant quand même
pas dans un ange pour répondu je parle
et tout
l'infirmière a terminé sa journée
[Musique]
les habitants de l'île retrouvent leurs
maisons
entourées par les eaux calmes du golfe
du morbihan
[Musique]
le lendemain matin les passeurs des îles
sont déjà au travail
sur l'un d'eux jérôme le capitaine
s'apprête à faire un trajet un peu
particulier
[Musique]
à nos liaisons d'un port à l'autre cette
fois le passeur des il va se faire
passeur d'histoires
avec un groupe
n'a pas de destination en fait on s'est
juste une balade et on revient ici
ensuite
jérôme navigue ici depuis 15 ans les
secrets de cette petite mer intérieure
l'ont toujours fasciné
ya plein de blanque c'est sinueux ça
devait être un endroit de pirate ici
parce que j'ai plein d'endroits pour se
cacher pour jouer à cache cache avec la
avec les douaniers enfin c'est sûrement
un endroit
propice à sable
pour l'aider jérôme a invité une guide
professionnel qui connaît tout de cet
archipel
[Musique]
sans le golfe du morbihan toutes les
îles sont privés à paris le moignic
d'art qui sont donc des communes les
toutes les autres sont privés
il faut savoir qu'à voir une île
c'est pas un havre de paix pour certains
quand c'est des héritages c'est un gros
travail parce que il faut entretenir
toute la végétation arracher les bouger
avec c c'est un gros gros gros boulot
d'entretien
[Musique]
le bateau s'approche maintenant
d'un îlot un peu mystérieux
la particularité en fait de r la mixer
qu'on va retrouver deux cromlech c'est à
dire des alignements de pierres dressées
nous vous avez un alignement qui sera
découvert que ce soit marée basse ou
marée haute et un moment vous avez des
pierres qui sont sous l'eau mais quand
c'est marée basse on peut voir également
le deuxième cromlech d'auxonne est
vraiment sur la période de la
préhistoire et ça montre bien qu'à cette
époque il n'y avait pas d'eau sur le
golfe du morbihan donc c'est à dire que
là où nous sommes c'est essentiellement
des plaines et les hommes en fait
marcher sur les plaines pour ériger
leurs vestiges
enfin
le bateau arrive en vue des deux plus
grandes îles du golfe du morbihan l'île
d'ars et l'île aux moines
une ils l'ont la plage de car postal est
connue dans toute la france
on
2 il encore aujourd'hui
rival
sont différents tout les deux l'île aux
moines nature du mondial est un peu chic
elle est un peu voilà alors que l'île
d'ars et un peu plus route fouet c'est
un peu plus sauvage
aurel et 2 et 2 sont différentes way et
revendiquent leur différence d'ailleurs
aussi
à choisir pourquoi briec
j'ai le droit de le dire
moi je choisirais l'île d'arz
la balade va se poursuivre
jusqu'à la tombée du jour
dans la maison de marie gabrielle tout
le monde dort encore
sauf elle
il est 6h30 la chef d'entreprise est
déjà au travail
notamment passé
il ya un patron lance ses plaies
yann c'est bon pas trop long
ce matin exceptionnellement elle passe
un moment avec sa famille
[Musique]
merci madame diallo
alors comment ça s'est passé ton
stagiaires
[Musique]
et pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
de mal maintenant tu me prends mon
téléphone tu seras gentil
que la mi temps avec elle les pauses ne
dure jamais longtemps à l'oit
oui
aujourd'hui marie gabrielle à un rendez
vous qui pourrait changer son destin
un chef de cuisine deux étoiles au guide
michelin se dit intéressé par sa
spiruline
alors elle met tous les atouts de son
côté
bonjour bonjour grand grand merci d'être
venue jusqu'à moi je suis ravie de faire
votre connaissance mais de même
alors je vais vous emmener votre veste
parce qu'à l'intérieur il fait chaud
mais ça c'est la température que j'avais
à l'année été comme hiver aussi
l'aspirine pour se développer a besoin
de 28 à 30 degrés
contre ces intrigues
vous montrez le cycle de production ça
peut prendre entre quinze jours trois
semaines un mois dans ces petites fioles
là parce que le but c'est justement de
ne pas aller trop vite de dire si ça se
développe de trop dedans et bien c'est
tout faux ah bah oui exactement à tirer
à bassam heures imaginez un pied à une
graine de tomate que vous auriez l'essai
dans un petit pot baril va s'épanouir
pierre moment donné il n'y aura pas ce
qu'il faut et elle va mourir
d'accord on la voit déjà apparaître
voilà ce que l'on appela je peux goûter
avec grand plaisir
donc en effet c'est vraiment une couleur
terre bouteille
c'est pas des effets de gélatine danger
at il pas du tout à
fait une crème ans
thierry drapeau le chef n'est pas
vraiment convaincu mais marie gabrielle
n'a pas dit son dernier mot laurier de
la couleur
elle propose ce qu'elle appelle son
caviar de spiruline
grâce à gré à gré c'est bien dosé un
là parce que je vais vous montrer
c'est encore plus unique au monde le
colorant bleu 100% naturels issus de la
mer il y en a pas c'est ce que vous avez
là
après
alors mon bateau
et cette fois le chef semble fasciner
aussitôt qu'on nous parle de bleu on est
un peu bloquée parce qu'on n'avait pas
avoir une couleur naturelle
sépare colorants et les colorant bleu
l'a vraiment quelque chose de naturel à
ce bleu c'est superman bleu du ciel de
l'océan c'est génial
maintenant si vous avez de 3 petites
chantillon en prête à me proposer je
veux bien ce travail grand plaisir pour
essayer maintenant j'ai besoin de faire
un petit peu l'enfant et puis de
campagne de type est
merci merci on va t'en merci bon courage
à vous et merci
au revoir
à nouveau
c'est chouette
si les tests sont concluants
le chef a promis de la rappeler très
vite
au chantier maritime
carmen elle fait de son mieux
[Musique]
elle sera bientôt première équipe hier
d'ici là les passionnés du sinagot
finniste préparer le bateau
c'est donc c'est soul la bande c en
dessous
il ya plus de 50 heures de travail sur
le bateau
la nuit presque oui on y presse de mr
remise à l'eau sauvage
6 2
mais avant la remise à l'eau
carmen un rendez vous important
depuis qu'elle vit ici
carmen recherche les traces de sa
famille son grand père maternel était
pêcheur il aurait même posséder un
sinagot
au siège de l'association
l'un des membres a promis de l'aider
ça va
aller là bas j'étais venu pour mes
petites recherches là dans un classeur
carmen conserve précieusement les
photographies de ses grands-parents et
de ce qu'elle croit être leur bateau
voilà cette carte postale la wii
japonaises tu vois pas ce que la loi
noir il ya deux noms ne peut avoir deux
ans de ce bateau là
le gros lot
voilà donc ce serait bien celui là les
voilà
1911 assainies il a dû servir transport
du mérite avec les chalands derrière il
a fait la pêche pendant 14 ans
alors 1911 1925
ceux-ci nago a donc bien existé c'est
miss et bah c'était c'était mon grand
père
ian à d'autres trésors à montrer à
carmen on va dire ce que tu en penses
tu vois souvent des bateaux il était que
deux
patrons à l'abri les
grands pas tout dit m take 2
dvd et faire la paix cher
pourquoi le parlement non mais ça
[Musique]
d'abord sur le village nous là avec ses
sabots
je crois qu'il est tout à leurs sabots
pour ça disent les deux
ah ouais ouais
[Musique]
[Rires]
le lendemain matin
le trois frères est terminée
comment ça s'est passé marcel sabbah
écoute très bien un bon chantier une
belle équipe
et malgré son grand âge le vieux bateau
reprend la mer
une fois de plus
et parce qu'elle a bien travaillé le
capitaine laisse à carmen l'honneur
d'être à la barre
[Musique]
ça fait du bien
à table
[Musique]
c'est vrai que j'ai voulu renouer avec
avec mes racines je sentais qu'il
fallait que je vienne ici parce que
c'était mon coin avec
avec les bateaux et de ce qui s'y
rapporte
seul allah qui sont autour de moi c'est
aussi c'est aussi une fratrie
1 un peu plus ouais
les paquets à marée basse le camp
alléché encore dedans
cette fois carmen se sent prête
dans deux semaines elle vivra le grand
jour
une sortie est prévue avec les trois
bateaux carmen sera première équipe hier
auprès de jacky
et leur navire devrait passer dans un
endroit unique que chaque marin se doit
d'honorer un jour
cette île au sud de port anna au beau
milieu du golfe du morbihan c'est lille
ils eurent
40 hectares de prairies de tamaris et de
plages de sable fin où personne n'a le
droit d'habiter personne
sauf vincent
le gardien des murs
comme chaque année au début du printemps
vincent s'apprête à vivre seul jusqu'à
l'hiver prochain
il y a cinq ans il a répondu à une
annonce lancée par le parc naturel
régional une centaine de candidatures
mais c'est la sienne qui a été retenu
la
maison d'édition web à l'ensemble des
maisons du village la fin 1-1 19e siècle
avait 25 30 personnes qui vivaient ici
en en permanence en quasi totale
autarcie petit à petit de vernon des
tanks à lait
les gens commencent à partir
là c'est le petit coin cuisine salle de
bain
voila voila l'espace de vie la table qui
me sert aussi de bureau l'e-book à
la vieille cheminée le petit salon est
donc là haut c'est la chambre lorsque
lille a été racheté en 2008 seuls les
murs des onze maisons du hameau avait
été restauré pour le reste tout est à
reconstruire
le parc naturel mais des moyens à
disposition de vincent
comme un robinson crusoé vincent doit
tout gérer seul sur son île déserte
et c'est loin d'être simple
pour l'électricité des panneaux solaires
ont été posés sur le toit de la grange
mais pour l'eau potable aujourd'hui ça
ne marche pas
vérifiées ou plus et ça marche
la seule source dit lure n'est pas dans
le hameau
c'est réparé ce soir vincent pourra
boire autant qu'il veut
en réalité vincent n'est pas tout à fait
seul sur son île
pour l'entretien de la végétation
il peut compter sur une aide précieuse
[Musique]
c'est le moment sympa ça
et à la moitié des troupeaux là on a un
beau petit troupeau reproducteur donc
l'hiver il ya un bélier donc on a des
naissances là au début du printemps
c'est une race rustique inquiets tout
aller dehors c'est une race bretonne qui
s'appelle les landes de bretagne qui a
failli disparaître dans les années 80
donc on contribue aussi à sauvegarder la
race que une race très très intéressante
parce qu'elle elle c'est l'été quand il
n'y a plus d'herbe profiter du voyage en
sous-bois des feuilles des yeux etc
[Musique]
à la fin de la journée
vincent fait toujours un dernier tour de
son île
je pourrais m'arrêter mais moi il ya
normalement il ya la tournée du soir
voir si
tout va bien sur l'île du coup j'en
profite je laissais de
deux convient d inventaire des espèces
d'observer de voir s'il ya des choses
à genia large
il ya quelques quelques tadornes
voilà il ya des échassiers la des autos
qu'il cherchait des coquillages dans la
vase et se nourrir quoi
un super on peut c'est que le reflet sur
l'eau là il est en train de projeter
encore dernier moment de la marée basse
pour aller chercher les verts là dans la
vase
sympa
oui
je suis pas d'ici donc pour moi c'est
une super école du golf ici là trop
milieu j'apprends plein de choses êtes
vous
j'ai grandi en région parisienne en
seine-saint-denis la ici je savais que
ça serait beaucoup beaucoup dehors je me
suis dit début est ce que est ce que je
vais pas me lasser ça peut être fatigant
de venir sans cesse en bateau d'être
toujours dehors tous ces travaux à faire
et tout ça est en fait je me surprends
et j'avoue qu'aujourd'hui les grands
espaces j'ai goûté j'aurais peut-être un
petit peu de mal à revenir
[Musique]
e
sur l'île d'ars ce matin l'emploi du
temps des dites est un peu bousculée
elle vient d'être appelé en urgence
c'est un enfant de deux ans qui est
tombée sur une pierre donc
qui s'est ouvert le front
donc je vais aller faire les premiers
soins constater si c'est nécessaire des
parts sur vannes c'est ici
ne paniquez pas ne paniquez pas
arrivée devant la maison l'infirmière de
l'île d'ars ne sait pas trop à quoi
s'attendre
à les voir ce petit bout là
[Musique]
la maman du petit garçon de deux ans est
inquiète
sans parler de de we are for les deux
points la plaie est impressionnante mais
heureusement sans gravité non c'est
presque fini c'est presque terminé
c'est bien sinon c'est bien aux quelque
1 7 et 1 garçon mais d'un courage
incroyable
et là en fait on a refermé la l'aplec
était béante quand même qu'ils étaient
vraiment très très ouverte et la
maintenant en fait le papa et la maman
vous ne vous prouve prendre le prochain
bateau pour aller sur vannes pour faire
des points de suture c'est génial on
fait comme ça
grâce au calme des dit parents et
enfants sont rassurés
parfait voilà alors mon petit simon tu
ne bouges pas mon p'tit père y en a pas
pour longtemps je te faire mais ça c'est
tout d'accord hop
on voit monter c'est mon
[Musique]
adorable etc et surtout très courage de
signer
agnès la belle-mère d'élite n'aura donc
pas de chaussons aux pommes ce matin
mais de toute façon elle avait d'autres
projets
la vieille dame s'apprête à partir à la
pêche avec son fils marco le mari d dit
à 88 ans
agnès n'est pas remontée sur un bateau
depuis longtemps
ils partent à la pêche à la seiche qu'on
appelle ici la morgate une tradition
dans le golfe du morbihan
la saison commence à glamorgan c'est là
pour la première on commence à pêcher
vous en cliquant les aubépines
fleurissent quand les premières petites
fleurs arrive sur les aubépines on sait
que les morgan elles sont pas loin de
passer c'est notre point de revers
tout petit j'allais à la tête mais on
n'avait pas de me taire c'était une
place en bois aviron et bien jamais bien
égalité
j'ai pas beaucoup ça
cette nouvelle politique
rien de rien
une macau 2
les pentes en couilles mais
c'est pas terrible pas 3 morgan qu'est
ce que tu veux c'est pas mal
moi si précieux temps à la voir ma mère
qu'à 88 ans moi j'en ai 64 à l'élever le
fils ensemble le matin quand il fait
beau comme ça une merveille
c
il ressenti
c'est ici le pays des druides de leurs
hôtels sont de bons taux c'est ici que
je tiens veillette
abordé jadis en chantant dans le golfe
où yolande et yvette dans le golfe du
morbihan
dont les bonnes feuilles au long des
rives est dans le golfe du morbihan
[Musique]
avait retrouvé son ambiance assez
simplement magnifique deux semaines
après sa visite
le chef a convié marie-gabrielle à venir
dans son hôtel restaurant au sud de
nantes
et thierry drapeau a fait bien plus que
ce qu'elle espérait il a imaginé une
recette qui raconte l'histoire de marie
gabrielle au départ voulait l'histoire
c'est les huîtres du tarbes pau on va
partir d'une nuitée puis après quelques
pas on va retracer un petit peu
l'histoire par pense que vous avez pu
faire
la north on appelait ça tartare de bar
et d'huîtres à la crème de spiruline
maritime
oh là là là je met un petit peu de temps
je mette de poissons et la crème de
spiruline
ça sent bon les noces d'or de rachat qui
fait ça quand même envie retrouvée en
fait que la mère ait pas trop en mettre
départ c'est comme très concentré 1
il n'avait presque trop déjà
après on va en profiter pour mettre les
petites picabia de spiruline est ce
assez de couleur là c'est unique c'est
une élection
c'est ça ces actes eux mansat
les gens des gens sont bien dieu c'est
vrai mais c'est vraiment on a vraiment
la merde
est-ce que ce que c'est une vraie
histoire en face et les bassins c'est la
spiruline maritime c'est le poisson
c'est bienvenu en très bien
le chef utilise maintenant le bleu qui
l'avait fasciné là on va mettre vitres
de dalat ajusterait dire
et pas la montée en chaleur pourquoi de
sa deuxième fille tout
plat de cuisson val a reconstitué
c'est absolument magnifique
ah non moi je suis comme un gosse la
ébloui voilà oui voir ma petite
spiruline marine révélée ainsi c'est
absolument fabuleux fantastique sans
quelques semaines
la spiruline de marie-gabrielle sera à
la carte de ce grand restaurant
[Musique]
à port anna le grand jour est arrivé
c'est la première sortie de la saison
avec les trois synagogues et carmen doit
être une équipière exemplaire pour jacky
son capitaine
carmen fait prête
qui est-ce qui peut m'aider là
on vas y c'est ici au mouillage il n'y a
pas de vent on prend pas de riz ça avant
de le reste force 2 donc on va aller à
ils eurent en passant par brouel
ensuite le thaï van
encore un prophète
pas d'erreur dans l'instant non non non
non mais
faut rester vigilant
m
[Musique]
depuis le bateau voisins les copines de
carmen lui ont même dédié un petit air
pour l'encourager
[Musique]
mais pour être une bonne équipe hier
carmen doit respecter une tradition en
passant devant ce rocher très
particulier
il est de tradition lorsque l'on passe
le moine de le saluer on le sait lever
si elle ne fait pas ça porte malheur sa
bourse mais
quand même il acquiert donc vous répétez
après moi
doublant le voit ni il faut saluer
double
d'un coup de blanc sans respirer
bon vent bonne mère est bon courant
nous porterons assurément nous
on est une petite goutte pour nos
copains qui sont plus là
oui
[Musique]
carmen et ses amis vont maintenant jeté
l'ancré devant la grande plage d'isle
sûrs l'île déserte gardé par vincent
aller
[Musique]
à tête
c'est bien quand même
c'est bien
regardez
le gardien de lille a l'habitude de voir
passer les amis des sinagots
[Musique]
vous sentez votre compagnie non non
c'est un banc plus maintenant que je
connais qui viennent les signaux sont
des habitués ils amènent des groupes est
certaine je vois tout le temps toute
l'année quoi donc ils eurent est fait
pour ça
samedi
m
parmi les amis du sinagot
carmen a trouvé sa place
[Musique]
avant de quitter le golfe du morbihan
nous retournons une dernière fois voire
et dit l'infirmière de l'île d'ars
c'est ma grande détente mon grand
plaisir c'est venir brossé mes chevaux
après la journée souvent le soir après
le repas même je viens les voir et ça
c'est
savait que du bonheur
marie-gabrielle quant à elle vient
d'acheter un terrain
[Musique]
elle veut y construire une grande ferme
pour produire sa spiruline marine en
grande quantité
[Musique]
non
heureuse ici là au milieu
c'est la terre de mes ancêtres
la mère qui les a nourris
ça veut dire quelque chose pour moi il
fait bien
[Musique]
sûr les eaux du golfe du morbihan
carmen et les sinagots ont repris la mer
ils ne sont pas prêts de la quitter
il
et
[Musique]